[Applause]
walking free after 23 years in prison
for the murder of his girlfriend but now
his conviction overthrown in part thanks
to a podcast I started looking for a
reporter who had covered the case Adnan
Saeed was found guilty of killing Heyman
Lee in Baltimore in 1999 but serial a
hit podcast from This American Life
highlighted new evidence and triggered
the review of his case and with 340
million downloads and Counting crucially
its popularity brought worldwide
attention and sparked an explosion in
True Crime shows I'm an ex-police
officer but a lot of my friends
absolutely love solving crimes they will
sit and they'll watch line of duty and
try and solve a fictional murder but
they will also sit and listen to
podcasts watch true crime documentaries
and try and figure out the truth and I
think it is just this need to
um to to find the killer to find the
truth to make sure that justice prevails
thousands of people looking to find this
guy True Crime is proving addictive and
it can mobilize the masses this Netflix
documentary about a cat killer saw
Millions engage in an online Manhunt in
2019
40 years ago Lynette Dawson went missing
Chris Dawson was found guilty of
murdering his wife Chris Dawson has
spent his first night behind bars at the
Sydney police Center yes indeed the
husband
and the teacher's pet podcast in
Australia led to Chris Dawson being
convicted for killing his wife Lynette
40 years after she went missing
True Crime is ever present in the weekly
Global podcast charts the intimacy of
the format lending itself to the dark
depths that listeners Venture down often
immersed in gruesome and morbid details
it's obsessive listening for amateur
sleuths I only learned about all this
because years ago an antique clock
restorer contacted me
and asked me to help him solve a murder
encouraging such sofa vigilantism can be
complicated The Producers need to be
really careful of two things one of
which is to not contaminate the evidence
to make sure that the Integrity of the
evidence is preserved the evidence that
they're discovering and of course the
second thing is to be sensitive to the
trauma of the people involved so that is
the victims of the crime and their
family members and also the wrongfully
convicted person and their family and
community and as appetite for True Crime
grows audiences now don't just have
power when it comes to ratings but also
it seems when it comes to tipping the
scales of Justice Claire Gregory Sky
News
[Music]